kathy wood by the way
was yesterday at the salt conference
shout out anthony scaramucci in the
whole team over there and when she was
on stage she was being interviewed by
andrew ross sorkin uh she predicted that
bitcoin will rise at least 10 fold 10x
to 500k a coin in five years that's what
she thinks now remember kathy is the
same person who said tesla was gonna be
worth thousands of dollars per share
ended up actually hitting those targets
and now with bitcoin she was in 2014
um she was one of the first if not the
first institutional investor on wall
street to put bitcoin into one of their
funds um and her price predictions
depend on whether companies corporations
continue to diversify their balance
sheet into bitcoin and institutional
investors begin to allocate
approximately five percent of their
funds into it and so andrew ross sorkin
asked her a bunch of questions one of
the things she said is if we're right
talking about corporations doing this
and also institutional investors
and companies continue to diversify
their cash into something like crypto
and institutional investors start
allocating five percent of their funds
towards crypto we believe that bitcoin's
price will be tenfold of where it is
today so she literally said that she
thinks bitcoin will be more than 500k in
the next five years i tend to think that
she is not only right but also somewhat
bearish here because it is likely to be
much much higher what do you think john
bearish is not a word i would use with
kathy wood and bitcoin
she has been bullish on bitcoin for a
very long time she's uh she's an
investor in innovation um i tend to
agree with her that obviously it is
dependent on more companies getting
involved and people allocating cash
towards the space
the one thing i was pretty surprised
with was that um she was talking about
other cryptocurrencies as well on the
platform and uh at the salt conference
but she's been embarrassed on bitcoin
for a while this is no surprise bullish
bullish
uh the thing i would say about that too
is like it's probably a little
conservative than what she actually
believes right because people are going
to hold her to it and they're going to
look for that prediction to be correct
and everything like that and that's only
if uh the things go uh where she thinks
they'll go but ultimately we've heard
people say you know 10x 20x 30x whatever
it ends up being they're gonna see it
significantly higher over the next five
to ten years and i think uh she's
obviously proven to be a big believer in
that kind of with not only her words but
her actions so i think that the number
is probably a little higher than that
like what she internally believes but
publicly uh she's giving kind of like a
more conservative or safe bet relative
to kind of the risk reward profile of
bitcoin i think bitcoin hits a million
dollars after the next half so 20x 20x
and let's go
[Laughter]
i'd be happy
and i think that she
although she's not talking specifically
about the uh having is going back to
this whole idea of its supply demand
right and the supply is known it's
certain it's transparent and it's uh
verifiable or approvable and so what do
you need to do she need to understand
the demand side which is she's
explicitly talking about she's
specifically saying that she believes
that there will be increased demand from
corporations taking the trillions of
dollars on their balance sheet
converting it into bitcoin uh not the
whole balance sheet but some portion of
it so diversification rather than just
concentrating in bitcoin and then two is
she believes that institutional
investors about five percent targets in
bitcoin over time and so if those two
things happen that obviously would be a
drastic increase in demand if you have a
fixed supply asset demand increases
price has to go up a lot and if you look
today we're about a one trillion dollar
asset give or take
10x would be about gold you know 500k
bitcoin about 10 trillion dollars with
the equivalent of gold if you really
think about it that doesn't seem too
shocking i think that's likely we will
definitely eclipse gold's market cap by
the
18 months
uh past the next happening so the next
halving plus 18 months by that point
we'll have eclipse gold to market alex
as in the chat would you sell it if he
got to that price
no why would you sell an asset that is
going to be the reserve asset of the
internet come on alex you've been
watching the show
yeah definitely not selling uh uh in
that sense and also i think that there's
a there's a huge piece of this that with
bitcoin specifically uh as demand
increases a lot of these companies what
they're going to start to do is they're
going to start to realize hey there's
massive manipulation around the
currencies and we talked about it i
think a little bit yesterday where uh
there's a lot of conversations around uh
oh the peso has devalued it x percent
compared to the dollar
which sounds great except for you have
two moving targets the peso is being
devalued but so is the dollar the dollar
is not a constant measurement of
purchasing power and so yes the peso has
been devalued at a faster rate than the
us dollar but the u.s dollar has been
devalued as well and so if you were to
compare it to something like real estate
or something that had much more
kind of structural
kind of value and holding of that value
you would realize that these assets in
terms of the fiat currencies have been
devalued at an incredible rate look at
bitcoin
bitcoin
and the dollar the dollar has crashed
aggressively against bitcoin over the
last five years
like it
just crashed falling off a cliff same
thing with all other fiat currencies and
so when you start to understand whether
uh it's real estate it's bitcoin you
know these things that people want to
hold as a store of value the fiat
currencies aren't holding up that
doesn't mean that they're going to go
away it doesn't mean that people aren't
going to use them as medium of exchanges
but what it does mean is as technology
lowers the barrier to entry and the
friction of switching costs people are
going to choose to use a store of value
that is not a fiat currency because
they're going to deem it to be a better
store of value that's all they're trying
to do is they're trying to store value
where can i put my wealth so that at a
minimum it doesn't get devalued over
time and at a maximum it can grow and
get me ahead that's all people are
trying to do this at the end of the day
that's what investing boils down to how
do i put my wealth somewhere so that
it's protected and it grows and right
now holding cash it's not protected and
it's not growing it's actually doing the
opposite it's losing and so you start to
look around the world and say where can
i do this
stocks
crypto
right real estate like there's assets
that it works but holding cashing one of
them yeah look that's exactly it right
it boils down to the simplest thing of
you're opting out of a system where
you're guaranteed to lose purchasing
power your dollar is guaranteed to lose
purchasing power and you're opting into
a system that has historically performed
uh as the best asset over the last
decade when it comes to risk reward
right when you look at different metrics
and stuff like that taking the
volatility in account and taking kind of
the percentage change and appreciation
into account it's been the best
performing asset over the last decade
from on the sharp ratio so you're opting
out of a system that you're guaranteed
to lose money and you're opting into one
where your money has uh appreciated in
value and your wealth has been stored so
i actually don't think uh
you can go through all the nuance and
everything like that but i think when
you break it down in very simple terms
it becomes a lot easier for people to
realize hey look everything is getting
more expensive around me the same money
that i made this year is not as valuable
the money sitting in my bank account is
not as valuable we have the money
sitting my savings account is earning
0.06 interest and inflation's 5 right so
i'm already negative there by a wide
margin it's going to continue to get
worse over the next few months and what
we're going to see is we're going to see
people opt out of that they're going to
start to learn and understand that they
should get out of cash and go into other
assets what's up guys bang bang a bunch
of you want to bring that trillionaire
energy every day and if you want to do
it in your financial life go use sofi
sofa is our exclusive sponsor because we
think they've got a great piece of
software that'll help you accomplish
your financial dreams go to sofi.com
today to get started you can invest in
everything from etfs to individual
stocks to cryptocurrencies to ipos and
they even have an automated and best
function head on over to sofi.com pomp
today and make sure you come back
tomorrow to watch more of the best
business show
[Music]